[Music]
breaking news this Thursday night Donald
Trump is indicted what's next for the
first current or former U.S president to
face criminal charges
calls to overhaul the RCMP the findings
from Nova scotia's mass casualty
commission there's no question there
need to be changes the forces failures
investigating Canada's deadliest
shooting rampage the Vatican denounces
the doctrine of Discovery these original
paper Bulls were all about the theft of
our land what some indigenous leaders
say needs to be done next L with the new
and in with the old now they're making
everything throw away questions about
Canada's proposed right to repair rules
aimed at reducing waste and saving you
money
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight nitu garcha
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with breaking news out of New
York tonight where a grand jury has
voted to indict former U.S president
Donald Trump he's now the first American
President current or former to face
criminal charges the case is centered
around a hush money payment made to
adult film star Stormy Daniels during
Trump's 2016 campaign our Washington
bureau chief Jackson crosco joins us now
Jackson what can you tell us well me too
this was a surprise to almost everyone
including Trump himself because in
recent days they thought that the grand
jury was actually backing away from any
sort of imminent indictment despite
Trump's prediction more than a week ago
that he was on the verge of in fact
being indicted as of tonight we don't
know what the specific charges are we
don't know what the indictment says
there's still a lot more to unfold here
at this point what we do know is what
you mentioned that this relates to that
alleged hush money payment case
involving adult film star Stormy Daniels
and we know that just in the past few
days the Grand Jury has been continuing
its work in New York hearing from more
and more witnesses in the case
essentially how this will play out in
the next few days now is that we will
have the indictment formally announced
by prosecutors in New York at which
point Donald Trump will be informed
Arrangements will be made for him to
turn himself in in Manhattan and nithu
at that point he will likely be
fingerprinted and photographed arraigned
before a judge and then likely released
on bail pending trial so Jackson this is
what many may consider an unexpected
development as you highlighted a big
question now where do we go from here
what happens to Trump now
you know a couple things first of all I
think everyone's watching to see how the
former president is going to react to
all of this he's already put out a
statement tonight denouncing the
indictment as a Witch Hunt he is saying
that essentially this is you know
politically motivated against him none
of this stops him from running for
president so very curious to see how his
campaign unfolds and how much of a
circus he may or may not want around the
history of being the first former
president to be indicted and facing
criminal charges we know you'll be
watching the developments closely for us
Jackson prosco in Washington thanks
Jackson
turning now to news in this country and
the heavy criticism of the RCMP over its
response to the 2020 shooting rampage in
Nova Scotia the mass casualty commission
has handed down its final report into
the worst mass shooting in Canadian
history it condemns the RCMP on several
levels for a lack of leadership and
failure to warn the community of the
danger over 13 hours a gunman killed 22
people across Nova Scotia including a
pregnant mother it's been an emotional
day for the families of the victims
there are 130 recommendations in the 3
000 page report Mike Armstrong is intro
Nova Scotia and has been pouring through
the details
the families of the victims pushed and
protested for this inquiry but this
final report may have been as much for
the politicians as for them the
commissioner almost right off the top
challenged those with power to listen
and Lead our recommendations call for
transformative change
they call for collaboration they call
for leadership
they call for you to Champion these
recommendations
some of the main findings of the report
deal with what was missed the
perpetrator had a long history of
violent and intimidating Behavior there
were years of red flags but no one put
them together his pattern and escalation
of violence could have and should have
been addressed as for that first night
in poor to pick the commission commends
the first officers on the scene but says
there were mistakes after that there was
no scene Commander 9-1-1 information
wasn't properly passed on and when
Witnesses told officers the perpetrator
was driving a fully marked RCMP Cruiser
police didn't believe them the inquiry
also finds police were focused on the
perpetrator but not enough on alerting
and protecting the public when our CMP
Communications did put word out the
commission says it understated the
threat the number one Mandate of any law
enforcement is ensuring that the
community is safe and on that day the
challenge we Face we weren't able to
keep that Community safe and for that I
am sorry
the commission also criticizes the
rcmp's treatment of Lisa Banfield the
perpetrator's common law spouse it
amounted to what the report calls
re-victimization and says she was in no
way any sort of a trigger for the event
a single charge of providing the gunman
with ammunition was eventually dropped
what happened to miss Banfield the way
she was treated in the aftermath of this
massacre which began as an assault
against her is disgraceful
the report makes 130 recommendations
more than half deal with policing and
calls on Ottawa to hold a comprehensive
review of the RCMP and to consider
restructuring its responsibilities it
calls for the force to recognize a duty
of care towards victims of mass casualty
events it says there should be tighter
control of police paraphernalia like
uniforms Badges and gear and it calls
for new Firearms rules such as lowering
the maximum number of bullets in a
handgun magazine from ten to five and
requiring a license not just to buy but
to possess ammunition to have this
report and know that
the families and the public have been
heard
is a fantastic thing
you know nothing can be changed but we
gotta we gotta move forward with
everything
one of the surprising things today was
that the RCMP commissioner hadn't
actually reviewed the recommendations
that despite the RCMP having been given
an early copy of the report yesterday he
did say he would review them eventually
and in fact promise to start a website
so the public can follow the Force's
progress with the recommendations online
nithu Mike Armstrong and Truro Nova
Scotia thanks Mike
a major announcement from the Catholic
church today one that some indigenous
leaders in Canada are welcoming the
Vatican has formally repudiated the
so-called doctrine of Discovery the
colonial era documents that justified
the seizure of indigenous lands in a
statement the Vatican asked for pardon
for the papal decrees that did not
adequately reflect the equal dignity and
rights of indigenous peoples and work to
rationalize immoral acts against them by
Colonial Powers indigenous groups have
been calling for the doctrine to be
rescinded for decades but as Heather
urac's West reports some leaders say
today's statement doesn't go far enough
500 years ago three decreased from the
pope set the stage for generations of
indigenous suffering and misery the loss
of land culture the horrors of
residential school all Grew From The
Seed of this doctrine of discovery which
said that when European explorers
carrying the flag or the consent of the
Pope would encounter non-christians they
could simply take their lands 500 years
later the Vatican says that was wrong
any language concept justification for
the colonizing powers to have taken
indigenous lands was wrong and should
never have been Justified it's a
statement that indigenous groups have
been waiting for when Pope Francis made
his penitential pilgrimage to Canada
last summer apologizing for the church's
role in the abuses suffered at
residential school there had been
disappointment that the doctrine of
Discovery wasn't addressed by the pope
then a statement now is welcome though
the national chief of the Assembly of
First Nations says it doesn't go far
enough we've asked for a legal uh you
know revoking of the doctrine what we
have today is a repudiation which again
is a step in the right direction uh it
just lacks the the action needed beyond
that that action according to Archibald
should include a new decree from the
pope one that declares indigenous people
have value and worth we need to get to a
place where we are actually seen as
having the same human rights as everyone
else across Turtle Island and we're not
quite there yet because evident in every
First Nation Community without access to
clean water or the over-representation
of indigenous people in Canada's child
welfare system and jails 500 years later
the scars of that Doctrine remain
Heather urich's West Global News Calgary
outside the Vatican Pope Francis is said
to be improving he's in a Rome hospital
after being admitted for a respiratory
infection in the past the 86 year old
pontiff has indicated he may step down
if he's no longer able to fulfill his
duties so his health may be more closely
watched than any Pope in history Redmond
Shannon reports
the world's media outside the hospital
where Pope Francis is being treated for
a respiratory infection there too a
statue of the last Pope to die while
still in the role John Paul II
news that francis's health is gradually
improving reached visiting worshipers in
the Vatican on Thursday our
theme today the busy Easter week begins
over the weekend with Palm Sunday
Hospital staff are optimistic Francis
can attend according to Italian media
when the late Pope Benedict resigned 10
years ago it set a new modern precedent
Francis has hinted he might follow
Benedict's lead if he were very ill but
more recently the 86 year old suggested
he would be reluctant to set it as the
new Norm that could elicit a certain I
mean appetite for Maneuvers in the
Vatican in the global church and he's
quite right about that in the past year
a knee injury forced Francis to use a
wheelchair and he recently has had a
recurrence of an intestinal issue that
previously needed surgery the decision
on just how ill he would need to be to
step down rests entirely with Pope
Francis himself the pontiff is due to
visit Hungary next month Redmond and
double news London in Tel Aviv it was a
night of protests Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu may have pressed
pause on a contentious judicial overhaul
plan but that didn't stop both people on
both sides from taking to the streets
demonstrators gathered outside the U.S
embassy to praise American President Joe
Biden's criticism of The Proposal but
hundreds also rallied in support of the
changes destroying property and making
veiled threats even against our own team
all of it showing the Deep divide
between left and right among Israelis
Crystal commencing Reports from Tel Aviv
billed as a Liberty March for and by
those who support judicial reforms
roughly 1500 danced and hailed the man
they lovingly call Bibi this is the
liquid flag which is also blue and white
the reason I took it is because they
left this
are using now the regular flag no one in
this crowd wants to be mistaken for a
leftist a sign of just how divided
Israeli Society is right now this rally
was the first since prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu was forced to pause
his planned legislative changes we're
not gonna stay silent for it because we
voted and we won this and we are the
majority the energy at this particular
rally fluctuated between jovial
and frenzied as a man with a party
flag was spotted
it's a band extreme right-wing group in
Israel he was quickly ejected then
attention turned to a temporary art
sculpture it was set up days ago a
creation noting that Elite Israeli
fighter pilots said they'd refused to
train if reforms were passed the display
was toppled
people took turns busting it up while
others tried to Shield them in the ACT
cameras were blocked and at least one
media crew was escorted away from the
area
in my case a man started shouting Al
Jazeera pointing at me and gesturing for
people to move towards me the group
eventually took to the streets blocking
traffic police were on hand but it's
unclear if the March was part of the
rally or just the direction the crowd
decided to go but there's no confusion
over the direction they want the
government to take don't they give up
the next session that we will have to
get the reform done given what we've
seen so far this week it's unclear if
when or how these divisions can be
mended more rallies are planned
including at the homes of members of the
knesset who the anti-reform side believe
could be sympathetic to their cause
nitu Crystal guman saying in Tel Aviv
Israel thanks Crystal
Natural Health Products under scrutiny
coming up ottawa's plan to tighten the
rules on things like vitamins and
homeopathic medicines
when we think of the word natural in
terms of health remedies many of us
believe that must mean the product can't
hurt us but that's not always the case
this week's federal budget includes a
proposal to further regulate Natural
Health Products in order to protect
Canadians Catherine Ward reports
a lot of people equate the word natural
with safe they feel that if it comes
from nature it couldn't possibly be
harmful and that's absolutely not the
case the federal budget proposes
amending the Food and Drug Act to enable
Regulators to take stronger action when
health or safety issues are identified
with natural products Natural Health
Products include vitamins and minerals
Herbal Remedies and traditional
medicines they're used widely by people
and we really need to see some
protection put in place so that
consumers can make better decisions
ideally we would have that system in
place already but the legislation was
not created at the time to include
Natural Health Products Bari power works
with the Canadian Association of
Pharmacists the legislation he refers to
is known as Vanessa's law which came
into effect in 2014. Provisions include
the ability to recall unsafe therapeutic
products imposed tougher fines and
penalties as well as mandatory reporting
of serious adverse drug reactions and
medical device incidents by Health Care
institutions currently Natural Health
Products uh there is no requirement for
healthcare professionals or consumers to
report side effects that come in
emergency room physician Dr Steve
flindle welcomes the move knowing
firsthand what could be at stake I've
had a young epileptic patient well
controlled on contemporary medications
and was advised to switch to zinc by a
so-called practitioner and unfortunately
the the patient went into status
epilepticus and wound up dying several
days later in an ICU while this note was
included in the budget there is no new
money earmarked for this change and the
timeline for implementation is unclear
Catherine Ward Global News Toronto
the right to repair next what's behind
the federal push for an easier fix to
your household items
the federal budget released this week
included plans for so-called right to
repair rules they're meant to make it
easier and cheaper to fix things like
home appliances electronics and farming
equipment instead of having to
completely replace them but as Toria is
re-reports how new rules could be
implemented Still Remains unclear Yeah
in our disposable culture
the brush roll and casing was worn out
here repair shops like this one are
becoming rare you're all set John
paravan owns vac Shack in Ottawa and has
fixed countless vacuums over the years
the older stuff is a lot better than
newer
products that they make because now
they're making everything throw away
I'd like to make sure that I've got good
service out of what I bought before it
just doesn't make sense to throw it away
but when it comes to all our appliances
and devices
sometimes it makes more sense to let go
I think we already had an issue with the
refrigerator and it was the same thing
again we had to buy a new one because to
repair it it was much at least the same
price as the new ones the federal
government insists it wants to solve
this consumer conundrum with something
called the right to repair to help
Canadians spend less money and cut down
on waste so this is a 1958 and it's
still running business owner Sylvie
Poirier has seen the life cycle shrink
and complications grow with parts less
compatible than before it's really
specific to the unit itself so let's
make it makes it more challenging and if
they don't have it well you got to tell
a customer sorry but business owners and
environmentalists say unless there are
tighter regulations Manufacturing
lecturers won't make products that last
for the Long Haul Europe and the US are
bringing in more regulations pushing for
longer warranties and better access to
spare parts as well as information since
complex programming and copyright laws
can complicate repair jobs but
accountability will be a challenge I
think enforcement's always a little bit
tricky it may be spot
inspections it may be complaint driven
they don't want you to fix them parts
are very expensive to get a part like
this is shouldn't be more than two or
three bucks
they want you to buy the whole head for
170. and until there's incentive to be
in with the old and out with the new the
right to repair may not be an easy fix
Toria esri Global News
Ottawa
next a British Commando reflects on his
daring feeds as he marks a milestone
birthday
[Music]
James Bond might have only lived twice
but one British Commando now living in
Ontario has enough stories to fill
several lifetimes Tom Bonham recently
turned 100 and is reflecting on his time
as part of the 30au a secret second
world war unit Mike drolet sat down with
the man believed to be the last
surviving member of this team
creeper behind him
throw that between his legs and twist it
and pull it and then fall flat in his
face and it's been 80 years but Tom
Bonham is still a Commando oh you told
that that's it
either you do that or you get killed
yourself the year was 1943 when a young
British officer named Ian Fleming
pitched an idea he'd create a top secret
Commando unit called the 30au which he
later used as inspiration for his James
Bond spy novels
was 19 when he volunteered for the new
unit all he was told was that it would
be hazardous why would you sign up for
something that says hazardous duties
yeah the teenager looking for preventive
it sounds good okay
it was only when they began training
that they understood they would be
different regular soldiers didn't have
to know lock picking safe cracking or
how to infiltrate enemy territory in a
submarine but Ian Fleming didn't
Envision his James Bonds to be regular
at anything now here's where Tom's story
takes a life-changing turn even so the
Germans still offer stiff resistance he
took a bullet to the shoulder during the
invasion of Sicily he woke up in
hospital with no ID he didn't even have
his beret after the war he moved to
Canada got married and never saw his
buddies in the 30au again yeah so there
were lots of reunions but because he'd
moved to Canada
um
he just completely lost touch then it is
until 2020 when historians Dave Roberts
and David O'Keefe found him and oh what
a shock it was to learn he'd been a
victim of friendly fire so you thought
for almost 80 years that a sniper got it
yeah yeah yeah no no one ever told me no
one ever told me I was so the Forgotten
Commando was now found and when he
turned 100 a few weeks ago a trio of
Commandos flew over from the UK to
present him with a statue and renew a
bond long thought broken it was just
brought it on again I felt as if those
three had been with me
80 years ago that we'd all been together
that's how I felt and still do before
leaving they gave him a beret only a
select few can wear the last of the
original Fleming Commandos made whole
again
microwave Global News tilsonburg Ontario
not as global national for this Thursday
night I'm Nito Garcia tonight's year
Canada is the wharf and Breakwater in
Port Morgan Nova Scotia thanks so much
for watching have a great night
foreign